hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game also from round one of
the currently played WR Chess Masters
tournament it's a game between the
andreasipenko and it's one of those
games that uh will make you again
believe in magic uh the positions that
happen in this game and the combinations
you have to find uh I don't know even
even if you sold 100 puzzles a day like
before breakfast I don't know if you you
will be able to solve uh everything that
happens here uh that being said that
does not mean you should not be solving
puzzles before breakfast you should
always solve at least 20 puzzles before
breakfast
um you will you know I either become a a
great player or you will lose weight or
I mean you're really going to enjoy your
meal uh it's a it's a win-win however
you put it but that being said let's
check it out as this is this is just
mind-blowing so uh Notre back has the
white pieces and he opens with D4 we
have Knight to F6 C for E6 Knight the C3
inviting the Ninja in defense and that's
exactly what the sipenko goes for the
names of Indian and there are many ways
to uh to play around this bishop to B4
move uh he goes for the standard line
Pawn to E3 which okay you can double
white spawns with Bishop captures and C3
uh but this is nothing spectacular now
white has a very strong Center White
will even play F3 e for we're gonna put
Bishops on E3 and and the D3 maybe
Knight H3 and we'll have a very very
solid game so this is not a serious
attempt for black especially not on the
absolute highest level so here just
castles with Bishop to D2 and now Pawn
to B6 yes prepares the I think his light
Square Bishop Bishop to D3 and now Pawn
to D5 uh very nicely done uh grabbing
the center C captures e captures and now
Knight to F3 the Knight is coming to
this E5 square and then you will cement
it with Pawn to F4 uh Rook to E8 we have
Rook the C1 and now the bishop um is no
longer useful and be before Bishop back
to f8 where it will uh serve as
additional support for Pawn to C5 push
so here Castle's Bishop to B7 and now
uh there is a game where fonta C5 was
played uh it was played in the in the uh
Serbian Team Championship
um uh uh in 2023 years ago between uh
Luca Buddhist and Alexander were pretke
won a very nice game uh but here we have
instead of Pawn to C5 we have Knight to
E5 uh and it is now as of move uh sorry
uh Bishop to B7 is the new move uh my
bad uh instead of C5 Bishop to B7 was
played and it is now as of move uh 10
that we have a completely new game so
Knights the E5 as planned with C5 now as
you do have additional support for this
push and pawn to F4 so you don't care if
black develops the Knight tries to
capture you will very happily play F
captures and E5 open up DF file for your
rook and you will constantly have a
pressure on that F6 Square so Knights
the C6 we have Knight to E2 uh very
nicely done now you are putting more
pressure to that C5 point but you really
want to bring your knight to G3 and then
you will have access to uh amazing
squares like F5 and H5 Knight to E4 and
now Knight the G3 and this is already
already on move 14 where the magic
happens uh Andrei plays Knight captures
on D2 and it makes sense it's it's such
a normal looking move to play you
eliminate the defender of the E3 Pawn D3
Pawn is a backward spawn you hoped to
put constant pressure on that E3 Pawn
pretty much for the rest of the game and
that's uh how you will play this but
Notre back does not capture back nope he
plays Bishop captures on H7 we've
reached a position from the thumbnail
and now okay you can see that Queen H5
Queen captures and F7 is coming but is
this really is this really enough so
let's see what he had in mind King
captures an H7 Queen to H5 with check
King to G8 and queen captures an F7 with
check and now the problem is uh you do
not have King to H7 you might think okay
King th7 and now we just have a
repetition with Queen H5 Queen to F7 but
this is actually a force to win for
white and it's quite a nice one Queen
the G6 check King to Jade and Knight F5
and it doesn't look like much but
there's uh nothing for
uh for black to do here even if you
trade some of the attackers like captors
captures Knight captures on F1 you can
even grab the Rook Rook captures and
play rookie seven you might be asking
yourself uh but where where where's the
mate what is this well E6 that's the
that's the problem for black and now
after Queen to E8 offering a queen trade
Knight the H6 with check King to h8 and
the Knight to F7 with check and now it
doesn't matter what you play King to G8
Queen H5 and the only way to stop
checkmate at least for the moment is to
grab the Knight here Rook capture spawn
captures nicely connecting with the king
and queen you have to capture Queen
captures on F7 with check and that's it
very quickly The Rook will come into the
action and Checkmate the black king so
you do not have King the H7 so uh Andrei
tries King the h8 but even this does not
help all that much Knight the G6 with
check King to H7 and now the Knight
comes the H5 and now when you look at
this uh yeah just very hard to believe
that there's nothing there something has
to be here and how do you defend the the
threat is pretty simple okay the best
pawn B7 is hanging but of course none of
you were looking at that Bishop uh the
real thread is a knight captures an f8
with check removing the defender of the
G7 pawn and then you just Checkmate the
blacking with Queen captures and G7 so
here there is only one defense and yes
benko finds it Rook to E6 you give up a
full Rook uh because now if Knight
captures an f8 with check then Queen
captures will defend the G7 pawn and
it's very tricky how to play this the
best way to play this is to capture The
Rook on E6 which is not what noderbeck
does and he does give Andre a one slight
opportunity to get back into the game
but I mean uh you'll see what happens so
uh in the game F5 was played but I will
just show you the win after Queen
captures on E6 because it's just
disgusting Knight captures on F1 Rook
captures on F1 and now of course Queen
to EA he want to trade queens now Knight
captures on f8 Queen captures and Rook
to F3 trying to get that Rook to H3 Rook
the E8 uh attacking the queen now
Knights the F6 this is the move you
would have to see if you actually played
Queen captors on E6 which is not a very
easy uh Queen captures Rook the H3 with
check and now you have to go back King
to G6 now comes Ponta F5 with check King
to G5 and now Queen capture 78
threatening Queen to H5 Checkmate and
there's just no move here uh for black
you you can capture but then Rook to H5
comes with the check you're gonna win
the black queen doesn't it doesn't
really matter what black does and again
you you will get checkmated here so
that's how you win with Queen captures
and E6 but not everybody played Pawn to
F5 and it's not getting any easier for
black however with perfect play it is
possible to survive this and uh in the
game Knight captures on F1 happened
which is perfectly fine fine Rook
captures on F1 and now Queen to G5 this
is where uh Andrei really uh sort of
drops the ball uh Queen to E8 was the
way to defend the position because now
Knight captures an f8 check Queen
captures and F captures on E6 you get
this position captures captures and it
looks really ugly for black but it is
possible to defend Bishop A6 and okay
let's say d captures D captures you're
gonna capture on G7 and uh you are up a
full Bishop you you are down three pawns
but you're up a full Bishop so you
should be able to play this but instead
in the game Queen to G5 was played
offering The Rook for the Knight on H5
and now look at this queen captures on
E6 we have Queen captures on H5 and now
Rook the F3 going after Rook to H3 uh
the problem is another bag already
sacrificed a whole lot of material just
to get this position and uh uh if Rook
to H3 uh the the queen just uh takes the
rook and you you do have sufficient
material for the for the queen so in the
game c characters and D4 was played now
uh it's even it's even better because
now if you play uh some like Rook to H3
then of course just Queen captures an
h3d captures and D captures and E3 black
has so much material for the queen two
Bishops and the rook and the pass Pawn
on E3 you cannot capture back because of
Bishop C5 uh secures the White Queen uh
and uh other than that you you really
don't have much to hope for here with
white it's still a draw with perfect
play but uh I mean an ugly way to ruin
such a beautiful position however there
is one move that wins the game for
another back here and it is the one that
um yesi pencil missed when he went uh
for for Queen to G5 instead of that
Queen to E8 move so feel free to pause
the video and uh do the magic for
another back while I give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the queen is completely trapped but I
don't mean uh via Rook to H3 the queen
is completely trapped via Queen to F7
this is what another big played and now
there is no move that saves the acipenko
uh the problem is uh Knight captures an
f8 check will pick up the queen and
there's no way to avoid this you cannot
uh really move the king anywhere you
cannot move the uh the the queen uh if
you play something like Queen to G5 then
just Rook to H3 check and again the King
has no squares you're just gonna deliver
a nice checkpoint even Knight captures
Rook captures and now a nice check a
forced checkmated with King captures and
queen to G6 Checkmate so here Bishop to
D6 was played espenko finds a way to
give up uh the queen and at least grab
some material but it doesn't help him
all that much Knight to fade with check
Rook captures on f8 now Queen captures
an H5 with check King to G8 and now Pawn
to F6 and yes you do have two Bishops
and the night for the queen and even
some nice pawns here but they are so far
away from the action it just doesn't
matter Knight the E5 is pink or tries
bringing his pieces to help out the king
but now Rook to F5 with pawned the G6
Queen to G5 not allowing the capture
Here and Now D captures an E3 espenko
creates a pass Pawn on E3 but now he has
to give up material Rook captures on E5
King to F7 you don't really get anything
by by capturing the because the G6 Pawn
is now also hanging you get checkmate
it's a king to F7 you have to defend the
G6 Pawn roof captures on E3 and now this
is really not enough uh for any sort of
serious counter play with Bishop to C5
you do win The Rook still not enough
Pawn to B4 even forcing this capture and
notice how nugget back always in every
game even if you can win the game
without playing a B4 he always plays it
and we can learn something from him uh
Bishop captures an E3 Queen captures
Rook to a right now it's a queen and a
queen against bishop and Rook but I mean
not much to be done here Queen to C3
defends the pawn on F6 also threatens
Queen to C7 check to win the bishop
because Rook D7 is impossible Bishop to
C8 and now Pawn to A4 it's time to
create a second weakness uh with Bishop
to F sorry not Bishop T6 Bishop to F5
and now I just Pawn to H3 creating some
breathing room for the white king Rook
to d8 preparing to push the pawn because
you already have these squares covered
but now Queen to D for blockading the
pawn not giving any control play to Yes
benko uh Bishop to E6 now G4 n1's G5
hits then the F6 Pawn is protected and
then it's merely a matter of time you
you will either get checkmated via some
Queen maneuvering or you will create a
another pass pawn and just win the game
that way it doesn't really matter also
A5 is coming so there's just too much in
White's Arsenal here so Rook the C8 we
have Pawn to G5 Rook to C1 check King to
the king they have to Rook the seat to
check King to G3 and he was in this
position on move 41 that Andreas panko
resigned to the game and what a magical
victory for another Beckham the satrobe
in round one of the WR Chess Masters
tournament now for those of you who are
interested how does um how does this
actually conclude uh like I said there
are too many weaknesses for black black
will have to keep an eye on the the
seventh rank because if the White Queen
infiltrates it's over now you just start
pushing and it doesn't matter like Rook
C4 You're Gonna Play Queen E5 now just
trying to infiltrate here if Rook C6 uh
you can even play B5 which would not be
possible if B4 was not played and once
you move the Rook once again Queen D6
and that's it now you can give a few
more checks like King F2 Rook the C2
checking E3 even D4 check if you capture
Queen to Rook the D2 check will pick up
the White Queen but it doesn't matter
King to F3 Rook the C3 check King F4 and
this is one of the positions that might
come up you are getting checkmated next
and
um not on the next move but in a few
moves and that's pretty much it uh so
yeah truly spectacular stuff by uh by
Abdul satrov and it's really remarkable
how uh how quickly it all happened I
mean like Knight captures on D2 it's
such a such a principled decision uh
that you would uh I mean you would
applaud like if you saw someone like if
you saw your child play this you would
say wow that's a very principal decision
uh but here it's exactly this principal
decision that allowed this spectacular
attack and the downfall of a great
player like Andreas benko uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
thank you everyone for for recommending
it it's truly an amazing game I would
like to thank Ricky blackcastle Johnson
Robert Trenton Rodney Barr and bullet
King for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on you one of the suggestions everything
that's happening in the Chess World and
I do have a very very special video
coming up up next so stay tuned for that
one it's gonna be absolutely amazing uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend